-Jennifer, you --
you play a TV host
on "The Morning Show,"
but a lot of --
not a lot of people
actually know this.
You actually started out
as a local-news anchor.
-Mm. That's true.
That's true.
-That's right.
-We did that back in the --
back in the '90s.
-That's right.
You say "we" did that --
It's funny, because,
yeah, we did it.
Yeah.
-We did it together.
-Yeah, together.
-People don't know this.
They don't know.
-No, we were co-anchors.
We were co-anchors at a station
in Great Falls, Montana.
-That's right.
[ Light laughter ]
-And this -- And the show
was called, "This Just In."
-Mm-hmm.
That's right!
-And this is where
we made our TV debut.
And it was --
-Mm-hmm.
-So much breaking news.
I remember this.
It's the one thing
I always remember.
Can I just tell you?
-Yeah.
Yeah, jog my memory.
-Well --
[ Laughter ]
-What I remember is that,
there was so much breaking news
that often we wouldn't know
what the news was
until we were reading it,
live, off the teleprompter.
-Yeah.
Oh! So stressful.
-Yeah. I know.
Well, guess what.
-So stressful.
[ Laughter ]
-I actually found
one of our old broadcasts.
-Oh, no.
-Yes.
-God.
-So, here, for the first time
in decades, is Jennifer and I
in "This Just In."
Check it out.
-Amazing.
-You're watching "This Just In,"
breaking news
with Great Falls' number-one
news team,
Jen Aniston and Jim Fallon.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-This just in -- it turns out
the Oscar Mayer Wienermobile
will not give you hot dogs
the way an ice-cream truck
gives you ice cream.
Trust me --
I found out the hard way.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This just in.
Breaking news --
a new study shows that an apple
a day can keep the doctor away,
but so can calling him
at 3:00 a.m. to say,
"Just thinkin' about ya."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Still developing, I don't
understand how microwaves work,
and I'm too afraid to ask.
So I just heat up all my food
by leaving it in the sun.
Takes hours, but it's worth it
for the soggy, cold lasagna
I shove down my throat
three times a day.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry.
You keep doing this turn.
Sorry.
[ Clears throat ]
This just in.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah!
-This just in --
turns out there is something
in the rules
that say a dog
can't play basketball.
Air Bud has been forced
to give back
all nine
of his championship rings.
When reached for comment,
he reportedly said, "Oh, nuts."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Stupid.
[ Laughter ]
-Moving on to weather.
[ Laughs ]
Moving --
-No.
-Moving on to weather.
Actually, you know what?
No, I don't want to move on
to the weather.
I don't want to move on at all.
I love you, Trish.
Please return my calls.
[ Laughter ]
I promise -- I promise to
stop screaming when we kiss.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Weather warning.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Weather warning.
Winter hibernation season
is coming, which means I --
I have to move out of my cave
before the bears come back.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-3-6-9, the goose drank wine.
Why local geese have been
breaking into people's homes
and drinking their pinot grigio.
More at 7:00.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Thanks for watching
"This Just In,"
breaking news with Jen Aniston
and Jim Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Those were the --
Those were the days when
we used to do that, right?
-Those were the days, my friend.
-Look at us now, though.
My thanks to Jennifer Aniston.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Season 2 of "The Morning Show"
is on Apple TV+ starting today.